اذا كانت القاعده في الهدا تسير وفقا
لقانون نيوتن الثالث بكل فعل رد فعل كيف
ترد الصين على تحركات المنافسين في
المنطقه الجواب في هذه البقره الصغيره
ارخبيل يضم مجموعه جزرا غير ماهولات تسمى
جزر سباركيلي وهي جزءا من نزاع الاقليمي
في بحر الصين الجنوبي مع فيتنام
ماليزيا والصين الكل يريد حصه من هذه
المنطقه لكن الصين وحدها تحركت كيف هذا
الريف
تضاعف حجمه 10 مرات منذ عام 2014 حفارات
هيدروكيه الصينيه شكلت امتدادا بحريا
للجيش الفلبينيه الذي رصد عمليه ازالها
قبل سنوات خطه لتوسيع اراضيها وعسكره
للمنطقه كما تقول الفلبيين
طلوحي ضاع ايضا في جزيره اخرى صغيره الى
الشمال قليلا لن كيان كاي المعروفه باسم
بناتا في الفلبين والتي تم تعزيزها بجدار
محيط اشبه باسوار باسوار القواعد العسكريه
وبركه بناء على صور نشرها الجيش الفلبيني
لا نزال في بحر الصين الجنوبي المهمه
اختلفت هذه المره قبل شهرين تحديدا ارسلت
بكين سفينتين الى مناطق الشعاب المرجانيه
قرب بنك المنطقه المتنازع عليها تناقشت
حولها الصين والفلبين قبل عام للتنقيب
المشترك عن ان النفط والغاز لكن يبدو ان
الصين غيرت الخطه تلعب في منطقه تطالب
بضمه اكثر من 80% من مساحتها تستند على
خريطه ان تعود للعام
1947 منطقه باتت تعرف باسم خط القطاعات
التسعه وما يحصل في جزر سبارتلي تطبقه
الصين وبصمت في هذه المناطق التاسعه
سيظل بحر الصين الجنوبيه المنطقه
الاقتصاديه الاكثر حيويه لدول الشرق اسيا
تصاعد التوترات في المحيط الهادئ ستبقى
الصين حريصه على توسيع نفوذها ومواردها
تحسبا من اي تحركنا مضاد